it's time for screen junkies movie
fights that's a great story let's pick
it up later hi everybody
movie fights in full effect I'm your
host Hal Rudnick and we've got an
exciting match today it's two friends
turned frenemies oh yeah
we're about to have a major collision
and let's meet our combatants
what is up Stacy Howard thank you for
being here thank you for having me this
is so exciting today I'm glad to be
amongst friends
maybe enemies at the end of this I don't
know what's gonna happen but it's gonna
be a good time
excellent I want you plug something oh
gosh well we have a show together
it's called six Wheaties a feature film
you can find us every Wednesday morning
at 10:30 and you can find me on Twitter
at Stacey Oh Howard no II know I just
why great and word on the street is that
if if if things like if [ __ ] gets too
raw here today your podcast is gonna end
yeah kaput so I'm just kidding you guys
will be friends after this but right now
we're gonna drop the gloves and let's
meet the other combatant welcome Brianna
Chandler MS movies is my name I have two
kids so I miss movies it's not that I
know all the movies it's that I miss
them oh yes you don't get around to get
around so write know something it's guys
I didn't see it
hey listen if it aint on TNT I ain't
seen it stars or TNT I neither okay cut
her cord cutter my friends write on
Netflix or Hulu I go Netflix all right
sure I don't have Hulu armour you know
what want to plug that podcast again
that podcast is six degrees a feature
film where you can find myself and Stacy
Howard I also do a show called film
therapy where we talk about how movies
affect our lives it's also on the
channel I mean you know what movies can
be cathartic they can be healing they
can be therapeutic yeah and they can
also scar you for life they certainly
can and I'm the film thing
I pissed I play one on the internet but
just for that show I might have to come
in and talk to you about the time that I
watched Human Centipede with my mom on
screen junkies you know it it brought us
closer together the way a traumatic
experience brings to people did you
finish the Fifty Shades of Grey trilogy
with your mom because I know that's
something they used to do they make you
watch that with your mama yes hopefully
my mom and I can what can watch Fifty
Shades freed yes and enjoy the boredom
so the way this works we have three
judges myself our fact checker and our
social media chairwoman
let's meet the rest of the judges
holding it down on the facts today mr.
lon Harris what up lon hey how I'm good
good to be here and uh first fact-check
of the show kaput so not a word thank
you for the verification on that that's
the kind of juice you're gonna be
getting at Ilan Harris today
thanks man Oh effects and checking out
all of your messages and on meme Patrol
Patrol Daniel Radford
hi buds hello um so as I explained like
every video if you guys want to vote in
the poll it is YouTube only there is no
Twitter pull the poll will go up once
the questions are up and both fighters
have given their answers so if you can't
vote yet it's cuz it ain't on there yet
what you want to do is you're gonna when
you're voting live turn annotations on
and off you can do that by clicking the
Settings gear icon on the bottom right
next to the fullscreen option turn
annotations on and off and then that
should refresh the poll so you don't
have to like you know click refresh or
anything like that keep those eyeballs
on our screen then you're gonna click
the PO in the top right corner of the
video and that is where you can vote I
will also be reading all of your
comments make them funny I love you okay
bye
nice Thank You Danielle so yes and
please send us those sick memes
send us your dank memes send us your
tired your poor your huddled means and
yeah we'll talk about them that's about
it they're great so again how this works
we have three regular round questions
which will be decided by myself and then
lawn and if we have a tie
boom we go to Danielle to let your poll
decide and then after those three
questions it's any person's ball game
because we go to a four question speed
round so one of our players can be up
three to zero but then come back via the
speed round
um I think we've pretty much addressed
anything LAN you feeling good I feel
great
Danielle you pumped so pumped somebody
for these sick maymays oh hell yeah
ladies are you feeling it need a puke
bucket no I'm gonna be okay
you know what puke live on the air that
is some good internet right Jay de roll
that packet
[Music]
so sick jte the best package in the biz
alright let's go to question numero uno
Wow okay it's a biggie
what is the best sci-fi movie of the
21st century so far the best sci-fi
movie of the 21st century so far is that
so far necessary I mean the best sci-fi
movie the top like why is this so far in
there just to be clear while picking
their favorite 2072 sci-fi movie okay so
you can't say Blade Runner Blade Runner
yeah absolutely not gotcha all right
good to know all right the best sci-fi
movie of the 21st century so far and
let's start with Stacy Howard okay so
the best science fiction film it doesn't
have to have an epic battle between you
know battleships it doesn't need a bunch
of like high-tech computers it simply
asks you the question about humanity
that we find impossible to answer now
because it hasn't happened yet so my
choice day is gonna meet director Alex
Garland's ex machina or is it ex machina
how should we sound like you said the
same thing okay all right movie as being
10 minutes from now meaning if a huge
tech company some big tech nerd comes up
and says we have an Ava she's here we're
gonna be surprised but we're not gonna
be shocked okay so that is the essence
of a great science fiction film is it
asks you not only what's our future but
how will we end thank you okay opening
salvo from Stacey Brianne Chandler okay
so the best science fiction film of the
21st century so far came out in 2006 and
it's a little movie that takes place in
2027 about a chaotic world in which
women have become infertile and an act
a former activist is going to agree to
take a now miraculously pregnant woman
to a sanctuary at sea and this is
children of men directed by Alfonso
puron starring Clive Owen Julia and more
and my cocaine and there you have it
great all right children of men ex
machina this is a real Sophie's Choice
for me ladies battle it out okay so I
could talk a lot about you know the
great visuals of this film that the
acting caliber of the three amazing
leads who are all superstars in their
own right but I feel like children of
men has that as well and I love that
movie so when I was trying to Rack my
brain about how to argue against this I
really went to what would be the ending
of these films now judges do ifer
mission to talk about the spoilers of
these movies they've been out for a few
years now is that okay children by now
that's on you you should see about these
movies they're amazing so in children of
men you have an amazing sweeping
dramatic story of humanity but I mean in
the end you know this crisis that they
have of women can't reproduce it's salt
you know the woman has the baby you know
is it's got everything it's healthy eyes
fingers toes to 10111 over and she gets
on the boat she's with the humanitarian
people and you know you have a happy
ending there you don't exactly know
what's gonna happen but it's implied
that now we have hope in ex machina guys
you have despair yeah exactly and I
wants a movie with despair I do that's a
real science fiction I want a movie with
hope I want to know that the gener
we're gonna have to rely on what's next
and that's what alfonso quran really
wanted to do he didn't want the movie to
to stop at the end credits he wanted it
to start at the end credits so that we
can discuss it even further beyond that
which is something that I like I feel
like ex machina gosh I've been working
on this argument for a really long time
ladies and gentlemen and I know you're
all gonna really hate me but I just have
to say the objectification of women in
ex machina is something that I don't
find to be make it the best science
fiction film of the 21st century because
it's something we constantly see women
are constantly objectified in science
fiction they put parts of women in a
wardrobe for God's sakes like if that's
not
objectification I don't know what is and
I just want to see something a little
more dynamic when it comes to gender
roles in a film well you could argue
that she wasn't even really a woman to
begin with but they gave sexuality Sheen
she's a computer she's trying to be
smarter than us so street shows she's
trying to use all her tools that might
be a bit other sensual tools everything
about her is about sex and because she
is going against a man but because she
is a man specifically put that they
added that to her they didn't have to
add sexuality but they did add the
sexuality and there's a reason they did
that they used it as a weapon because
that's the whole point of a touring test
is to see if a machine is gonna be like
human like and if you can tell they are
machines they're gonna train you yeah
but I'm the one out there to Spokane
he's going against a or she it is going
against a young shy boy you could say
what domhnall gleeson character is and
it's trying to use everything on her
arsenal to beat him and she ever games
you got Kali 9000 didn't have to have a
relationship with Dave in order to bring
him down in 2001 a Space Odyssey but yes
she the 2001 a space I'm just saying we
could do it without having to sexualize
a woman I didn't I didn't see her as
sexualized in a sense because she was
made of his porn preferences how is she
not sexualized yeah but that wasn't her
fault though that woman that was shunned
always if that's my I think that she she
was given an order to rise above it all
which is exactly what machines do
they're not human they don't see
themselves as objectified or as anything
horrible happening to them they just
know that in in the end they have to be
the superior race we are the inferior
once once we are discovered to be dumber
than these human beings I mean that's
our future right there is the machines
escape she kills them she gets well
kills them they don't actually do the
end but she gets out and she has in a
sense achieved victory because she used
everything that she had that's what
machines do she's not a woman she's an
it now listen I want to go back to
children of men and tell you why it's
superior to ex machina and that is
because it is so of our time right now
especially with the wake of the European
migrant crisis of 2015
the presidential election 2016 the
refugees that were seen right now this
is real this is ten minutes from now so
I feel like we are living in a very
children of men world and because it's
so depiction depiction of what we are
going through right now that's why I
feel that it's superior to X - I will
see that and I will raise you the same
thing that an ex Makani we are
absolutely going with this theme of what
is technology done to us what has been
you know available to like companies
data usage or data mining or whatever
it's called that they use everything
against us in order to achieve their
financial economic technological dreams
and it's eventually going to destroy us
and steal who we are as a society as
mankind we are going I would rather see
the home I would rather see the hope of
the future which is what we're seeing
right now pull back and take an overview
for a second I'd love to hear from both
of you what constitutes a great sci-fi
film and then tell me how your movie
fits in but I'd love to hear it just in
general what what you feel constitutes a
great sci-fi film Stacey you started
earlier so we're gonna start with
Brienne right now to me what constitutes
a great sci-fi film is something that is
very reflective of society today
something that you would say this is
where we'll be in 2027 maybe we will be
there I feel like maybe that's a little
early but I I like science fiction that
is very real and I like science fiction
that has a message of hope at the end of
the day my personal preferences great
and and how does your film fit into that
my film fits into that because it does
have themes of hope and faith you know
it is like basically the story of Mary
if you will and modern-day Nativity and
I just like I I like how its laid out in
terms of the story is not presented to
you so concretely it's not told to you
in a narrative setting like we're gonna
tell you every step of the way what's
happening you have to kind of figure
that out for yourself I also like a
science fiction film that when it ends
you are talking about it
all the time I mean I'm talking about
children of men today and I wouldn't be
talking about that I don't know before
it happened but I'm glad that I'm
talking about it now
sure and you know we did ask you the
question yes so that's partly why you're
talking about it nonetheless yes last
time I was on movie fights yeah I
actually brought it up in my argument
for Blade Runner because I they asked
what was the best movie of the 80s and I
said it's Blade Runner and Kevin Turan
of the LA Times says that children of
men is Blade Runner of this century
maybe instead of Mis movies you should
be Mis children of men okay Stacey talk
to us about your definition of a science
fiction film okay a truly great science
fiction film doesn't stay with you
because everything worked out in the end
it terrifies you because it shows you
our ultimate fate and admit and makes
you admit something that you don't want
to
so children of men is great but ex
machina in my opinion is going to
outlast it because of that ending I love
both both movies I think they're on that
that same spectrum and same genre of
it's not so much of a high tech it's
about what's going to happen to us but
one answers that in a very positive
hopeful light but for me that's more of
a fantasy genre for science fiction I
wanted to show us what's going to be our
ultimate downfall what is going to take
us to extinction gotcha
and how does your film fit into that I
mean it just shows you are our ultimate
strengths are gonna be the ones that
bring us down in the end so I mean yes
we are you know these great conquerors
and when we have the knowledge to build
all these tools but those are ultimately
going to destroy us because we weren't
strong enough in in ourselves in our
hearts do not let us let it overtake us
gotcha
final thoughts if you want to take down
the other person's movie or any last
Barb's after a time Ava's just gonna
shut down and just kind of like be on
the side of the road like I've got my
batteries around
no I think she's gonna find a way she's
smarter than solar powered she
overpowered an out thought and
outsmarted these two men who were some
of the most brilliant minds of her time
and she wasn't even human I mean but she
played to their their human weaknesses
which is ultimately was gonna happen to
us because they don't have machines and
AI it doesn't have the human feelings
human insecurities human faults that
we're gonna have it's the strongest
parts of us in every sense time Wow what
a colossal battle man versus machine
children versus maken uh this is a great
battle I love how you both tied this in
with some kind of relevance to today how
we are it makes sense that we are ten
minutes away from this kind of AI being
infused into our lives I mean it seems
like every CES we're seeing something
that's a step closer to that and breanne
you also tied your film into today with
the refugee crisis going on in Syria
Europe etc the the political derisive
nasir in America so there was a lot of
interesting stuff so then I go to your
takes on your films and sci-fi so you
were preaching more of a darker vision
of sci-fi you wanted a sci-fi with hope
I mean from where I'm sitting as a judge
those are both subjective opinions and I
don't think there is any hard and fast
rule so I wasn't sold on that either way
that just seemed like personal
preference so it just gets down then to
the actual nitty-gritty of this of your
films and at the end of the day you had
you had some interesting food for
thought talking about the
objectification of women in the film but
I think you did a nice to use a fencing
term parry when you brought up the fact
that Dom Holly
since character was like a child he was
putty in her hands and he was
manipulated and it was relevant to the
storyline and and you I think you
dismissed that criticism well and I
think just as far as the groundwork that
you that you laid with the impact of
your film at the end of the day I got to
go with Stacey and ex machina lon
well first a fact to add in so Alex
garland has been asked about how does
Ava recharge herself once she escapes
the lab his theory is that she has some
sort of technology like induction plates
that she could easily you know plug
herself into the power grid outside and
which garland doesn't think that would
be an issue that Ava would be able to
tell the apocalypse who live on as long
as she can access there like a Tesla go
to a supercharged station and hook
herself in in terms of the arguments I
thought yeah when we also got a mention
of the Turing test that of course tests
a machines ability to exhibit
intelligence that's indistinguishable
from a human so that's how the Turing
test goes I can't tell if I'm talking to
a machine or a person sometimes I feel
that way when I'm talking to you because
you are a robot of knowledge that's kind
of good this sounds almost good in terms
of the in terms of the fight I thought
everybody did a really good job
especially of yeah as you said making
the case that their film sort of has
relevance it's speaking to something
that sort of matters about the modern
world I kind of thought that was a wash
unlike you though how I actually thought
that brianne's argument about ex machina
sort of objectifies women in this way
that's kind of unnecessary for the story
that it's telling I actually thought
that was pretty compelling and I didn't
really think that we heard you know a
total counter-argument to that we sort
of got like within the within the
reality of the movie Ava doesn't feel
objectified cuz she's a machine like I
agree with that but sort of the movie
doesn't really necessarily need that
angle I thought that was a really
interesting take so I'm going with
Brienne boom we are locked up at 1:1 Wow
Daniel Radford alright so as
right now on the polls with 65 percent
to 34
the polls are spoken and they are going
with ex machina and so just just a quick
things a lot of people were talking
about inception lot of Donnie Darko a
lot of attacked the block people want to
know what is on house lapel which
interesting only enough before the show
started he was like yeah we've sorry how
they think it's a brooch oh really
we got a color can we get a poll and on
Twitter we've got Johanna at artists
reward saying dancing ask Oscar ivic
versus Clive Owen saving the world is a
tough choice
I was surprised we didn't get more about
the banshee Brienne it may have served
you if you did a Michael Kane impression
all I have is the name my cocaine my
cocaine oh my cocaine my cocaine I'm
gonna keep that one in my back pocket
with my cocaine by the way I want to
give a shout out this pin it's an owl
from my buddy Joe he gave it to me and
check out his stuff at pin fiend pin
fiend calm Isis an owl if their
significance to being an owl or it's
just that well you know what I like to
think it's one of the aisles of Ga'Hoole
[Laughter]
for best sci-fi fantasy fantasy all
right it's one Oh Stacy Howard let's go
to the second question
this is all because Scott manse didn't
return my call
oh boy 18 pitch a 2018 film version of
any musical 2018 film version of any
musical we're gonna start with Brianna
Chandler
alright this musical opened in June of
2003 at the San Francisco Coran theater
you may know it as wicked which tells
the story of two unlikely friends
Elphaba and gelinda who later changes
her name to Glinda
you know the Wicked Witch of the West as
well as the Good Witch who struggled
with opposing personalities and
viewpoints and rivalry over the same
love interest the reaction to the
Wizards corrupt government and
ultimately Elphaba's fall from grace
this is based on the 1995 a novel by
Gregory Maguire titled wicked the life
and times of the Wicked Witch of the
West with music and lyrics by Stephen
Schwartz and right now which I just
discovered as of February 9th 2018 with
its five thousand nine hundred and
sixtieth performance it has surpassed
ocal coda to become Broadway's seventh
longest-running show the first one is
Phantom of the Opera it's got a ways to
go to get there it's got at least like
10,000 more lots of stats lots of stats
what about cats cats is now and forever
cats is not up well I might be up there
in the longest running also wicked is
the second highest grossing musical of
all time passing over a billion dollars
just passed phantom and it is right
under the Lion King lion Kings got those
bucks you know
I didn't pick Lion King though cuz
that's already coming out yes okay so
wicked
Stacey alright here we go my choice is
gonna be singing in the rain directed by
Michel Gondry okay so when I think of
the great visual films of our time my
thought always jumps to Eternal Sunshine
of the spotless mind which is Michel
Gondry's film it's one of my favorite
movies and it's it's a simple story a
boy and a girl break up and get back
together but Michelle country takes his
wildly imaginative visuals and adds it
to this story that has such a fluidity
to it and such a back and forth these
these great visual
story and we're making us a musical yeah
it's a musical I'm about to dog you at
home yeah yeah c'mon girlfriend I would
be excited for Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind the musical I'm saying no
gondry but his past
IMDB films Network is gonna tell you
that he would be a great choice for the
director of this movie so directors
today they don't have quite the the
pacing and the movement and the timing
that a musical of the forties and
fifties would that was coming off kind
of the vaudeville esque era where you
have the it's like it's a Broadway stage
and you're playing to an audience so if
you look at Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind that really has that same
tone to it so if I want to take a
traditional musical that is
happy-go-lucky that everyone loves but
hasn't been revisited in a while I want
to go with singing in the rain because
it is a beloved favorite of people the
world over and I want to bring it back
into the stratosphere with a modern
director who has a modern image for
musicals it's very difficult for a lot
of directors to do that today he is one
of the ones that could do it
great slug it out you too my problem
with him my problem was singing in the
rain is first of all the original is
amazing and I just watched it actually
three weeks ago with my daughter it was
the first time I had ever showed it to
her she was asking about Debbie Reynolds
it's a long story
I'm not gonna get into all that but
anyway she was asking about Debbie
Reynolds and I was like let me show you
a film with her let me show you the best
film with Debbie Reynolds and it is
singing in the rain the duo of Daniel
O'Connor Gene Kelly and W Reynolds that
as far as acting singing dancing
everything about them I just don't know
how you would find actors that could
come to that caliber could come to that
level I don't know I just don't know if
anyone be able to do it and I know that
Michel Gondry's done a ton of like music
videos and I'm almost tempted to say
what if David Fincher were to do a
singing in the rain remake that I
actually spark my interest I'm really
dark but I really I think I would be
most concerned with who he would get to
choreograph this because that is where
my interest lies is who's going to be
making up these dance moves I feel like
I don't know scene in the rain the
original
is Debbie Reynolds behind the curtain
and this new one is gonna be the actress
in front of the curtain and then they
lift it and they're like oh yeah the
better ones behind why was I even
looking at this one in the front if you
know singing in the rain you know what
I'm talking about some deep cut singing
in the rain references all right so uh
well I'd love to hear from both of you
who would you cast in these in these
modern eight versions of your films
first of all I didn't give my director
so I apologize for that Kenny Ortega is
one that I would pick to direct wicked
because he just has a long history of
directing musicals he's behind the High
School Musical franchise as well as the
descendents franchise he also did
Newsies and he's not just a director but
he's also choreographer and that's kind
of why I picked him because dance is
very important to me but for Glinda now
we got it I would love to go with the
original actresses but we have to bring
this to a younger generation so for
Glinda I'm gonna go with Taylor Swift
and for Elphaba I'm going with zendaya
mmm that's what we're looking at there
got to bring it down bring it down some
my daughter would want to see it which
she loves India and if we throw Zac
Efron him there she's automatically
gonna see it she has to see everything
that Troy is in that's a high school
musical reference gotcha
Stacy who would you cast in your update
of singing in the rain all right so for
the two male leads you need to go with
someone who is charming sweet and
ultimately you're your greatest fantasy
for you know gentlemen so I'm gonna go
with everyone's favorite dad like
characters up Paul Rudd and James
Marsden who we both know have great
movement we saw James Marsden and
enchanted so we know that he is gonna be
a great presence on screen I think Paul
woods charming and comedic timing
everything is going to carry us over so
oh sorry so just to clarify who's in the
and it's Donald O'Connor by the way
who's in the Donald O'Connor Daniel NORs
who's in the Donald O'Connor role who's
in the Gene Kelly role um for a Gene
Kelly I'd go with the James Martin role
he has a little more experience I would
say in the musical era so we're gonna go
with that and then for my female lead I
also chose us and I
because she is the hot ticket the moment
and she's amazing and she just proved
yourself in the greatest show man so I'd
love to see more from her gotcha I'll
throw another question out there um why
do we need your movie right now
wicked it's been around for several
years it's never been made into a
feature film in the rain it is a classic
why do we need this right now jump in
there for singin in the rain the
essential question of it is what is
gonna happen to the film industry during
this transition Ferris is gonna be you
know it's from silent films going to
talkies house is gonna affect us all
that can absolutely be translated today
because everyone wants to know what's
gonna be streaming like versus you know
in the theaters how's everything going
to be affected in the film industry with
like CGI actors are they real actors
should they be nominated for awards
there's a lot of the technological
advances that are going to be argued
about how does that affect movie-going
audiences and filmmaking so you get you
don't necessarily have to do that same
subject matter you could transition it
and adapt it to today I think it's
absolutely essential that's why we need
it now we're asking all those questions
now okay we need wicked right now
because we have actually not seen wicked
ever done before in the theatre and
musicals are hot right now because of
the greatest showman let's do something
that was on Broadway that can be on the
screen that we would like to see for the
first time so we can make it be the best
one that we have ever seen we already
have the best one of singing in the rain
so we don't need an updated version we
don't need a changed updated version we
have already seen Michel Gondry's style
of filmmaking done as a musical it's
called the umbrellas of Cherbourg or
however you say that I'm not quite sure
what do you say over there so I haven't
quite heard from you why is wicked a
lesser choice wicked I mean I saw that
you know as a young Broadway esque
dancer gal with all my friends and I was
incredibly moved by but I loved it but I
feel like with the the soundtrack that's
been so popular and now
idina menzel with frozen it's all a
little bit saturated you know it's it's
been on the minds of everyone for a
while I want something that maybe has
been not forgotten about but that we
need to revisit because it's like a it's
like an ex-lover that you hug it's like
a teddy bear you find from your
childhood you're like oh yeah I did love
that thing oh wow I'm so happy that this
is here you want to remind yourself of
the happy perfect times of when you were
a kid and I think singing in the rain is
gonna translate across all audiences and
just be perfect for this time and why
should we either not remake singing in
the rain or why is wicked a better
choice well why wicked is a better
choice aside from the fact that we
haven't done it before but we've seen it
so much in popular culture without ever
being something that's been on a main
screen we've seen in Glee brothers and
sisters the Simpsons South Park new girl
Zombieland Drake has sampled from the
song popular' like it's everywhere and
so it's time for us to finally get it to
finally see it realized on screen I just
think it's time I'm ready to give it my
money tomorrow time Wow the witch versus
the rain you know I'm gonna work on that
one why oh yeah which gets melted oh I
called time there's one more thing that
Stacy and I wanted to oh did you have a
sound plan oh we have a pitch we like
together we're gonna catch you guys on a
movie what on a remake going rogue this
is not gonna do we're gonna take Xanadu
Xanadu we're gonna update it and call it
xanax no no no it's gonna be directed by
tobe Hooper yep from Texas Chainsaw
Massacre to be also going to be starring
zendaya yeah we love her we love her
she's gonna be in that in the lead role
Olivia newton-john we're gonna throw out
pretty much the script because it's
terrible I'm gonna keep eating
yeah the muses mm-hmm the original song
yeah I'm gonna get the guys from lala
land who did all
we're getting show man we're gonna do a
whole new thing guys Danna dude we're
gonna bring back skating yes then we're
gonna bad I've given its due that's
right so we want to do it correctly this
is ready the wildest craziest nut bag
story you have ever seen on film it's
gonna be amazing written by Luke the
song
yeah it's written by Luke that's right
the original Xanadu also starring Gene
Kelly as well his final film you know
what this has no bearing on the round
but I like the fact that you you said
the director was toh Cooper he's the
director of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
speech and like lame is Iran no no
that's Cooper you're saying Hooper he
say let me say tobe Hooper here say Tom
Hooper tobe Hooper the director of
goddamn Leatherface zooming past the
most important thing tobe Hooper to
octobe Hooper directing Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the musical thank you thank you
for that extra delicious morsel let's
forget that last part and talk to me
about that battle it was like where did
they get okay cats is the number four
longest-running Broadway show of all
time seven thousand four hundred eighty
five performances Trent Reznor and David
Fincher are working on a rock opera
based on Fight Club whoa yeah get your
David Fincher musical I wish may come
true in terms of the fight I thought it
was a really interesting fight I felt
like Brienne got a little hung up on the
we've never seen a wicked movie before
whereas we've seen singing in the rain
it wasn't that compelling to me because
audiences today love their musical
remakes Beauty the Beast was huge Jungle
Book
so I wasn't pretty animated to live acts
I wasn't sort of that what / and I
really liked I wouldn't like to hear a
little more detail but I really liked
Stacy's idea about how this moment in
filmmaking sort of matches the singin in
the rain moment where everything's kind
of in flux it's an interesting time to
look at the industry so I thought that
was pretty compelling so I'm going with
Stacey thank you on one Oh Stacey yeah I
thought you both had interesting choices
and it it came down to the execution
because I thought they were both
potentially valid Stacey I thought you
had some great information in regards to
modernizing the story and I just think
of like a timeless tale like a star is
born I know that you didn't bring that
up but just it made sense to me your
argument there and yeah I I know I feel
like I didn't quite hear enough on this
end as to why we need wicked as opposed
to like long said we just haven't seen
it yet so because of that both
interesting choices both strong casts
and directors but I'm gonna go Stacey as
well so Stacey is Stacey takes the point
Wow
let's go to Danielle tell us about some
dank memes again this isn't you know I
don't count but it's great that y'all
did it um 74 to 25% in favor of wicked
Wow
I won't read there were so many like
really good tweets and stuffs and we try
to blow through these please at CW
underscore Berkshire says I need them to
make the musical of Grey Gardens into a
film he thinks Amy Adams and Laurie
Metcalf as the two Edie's that is
amazing at fast dave 17 Guys and Dolls
with Bruno Mars and the Sinatra role and
Michael Fassbender and brando's role Wow
well Jack Shipley like I can't read all
of these but he has a great take on a
postmodern dystopian version of The
Sound of Music with the Von Trapps
hiding underground
and San TS daddy won on a wrote reboot
Little Shop of Horrors with Hallisey
more yeah someone here was in a
production of grease I don't know who it
was
but could have been how ironic yes in
high school I want yeah I was I wanted
to be Kenickie because he gets to sing
greased lightning yeah but I ended up
being cast as Vince Fontaine which is
not like a plum role he does get to Mack
on Marty Marty at the dance
so I remember that in my high school
days yes indeed let's go to the third
question it is - Oh Stacey what 3mc you
ladies heroes or villains would you
assemble for a team-up movie wow what
three MCU the Marvel Cinematic Universe
ladies heroes or villains would you team
up for a team-up movie and we'll start
with Stacey okay so these are my three
choices I'm pretty excited about them
I'm gonna go with Valkyrie nebula and
mantis okay so I just saw Korea and
nebula because they are gonna go butt
heads the entire time and play off of
each other really well they're both
really compact complex characters they
have motivations way beyond wholly good
or wholly evil they've got really
interesting character arcs which I want
to explore more in their total badasses
okay so you got all that snark you got
their mischief you got their kind of
evil good bad side going on you need a
good balance of wholesomeness and of
sweet naivete so I tossed mantis in
there she's gonna come in so she's
constantly gonna challenge anything
nebula and Valkyrie are going to do
she's gonna try and steer them in the
good direction she might use their
feelings against them and some kind of
you know comical fight where they're
trying to battle each other and then she
tries to get them to you know reveal
themselves cry laughs whatever
sensuality who knows what's gonna happen
there and you want to see them change
okay so you're gonna see how they all
play off and come out the other end so
those are my choices for the three great
Thank You Stacey Brianne talked to us I
also chose Valkyrie as one of the ladies
that I would like on my team as well as
Black Widow and Cherie and I want to
have these three ladies first of all
Valkyrie and Black Widow I feel like
they they could have a little bit of
issue with each other only because maybe
one feels like they should be the leader
over the other but sure he's gonna be
there for that comedic relief and be
able to be your tactical person that's
going to be able to get everyone up and
running and if is and if necessary is
going to fight it depends on also how
we're gonna do this like are we gonna
use certain things from the comics or
are we just gonna use things from the
movies and if so then that limits Cherie
just a little bit because in the comics
she becomes like a black panther at some
point but she still has a lot of
kick-ass skills as most of them do not
truck skills you know other skills like
that right on fight it out ladies well I
feel like we both pick Valkyrie so it's
kind of a wash okay well not necessarily
how would you each go about using
Valkyrie how does Valkyrie factor onto
your team well let's talk a little about
what the story could be I am vision the
story being that there is perhaps some
sort of you know like like sex
trafficking or slave trade kind of thing
going on where they are
help there's a no sorry going to a group
of women they're held captive and they
are trying to free them so they all feel
like I kissed the girls but with the
Avengers but Lady Avengers okay see you
got dark they all feel strongly that
that's what they want to accomplish is
to free these women but obviously
they're all gonna go about it in a
different way so you want to see all of
them change and kind of see how they
affect each other so Valkyrie and nebula
I mean Valkyrie has like some raging
alcoholic going on nebula has some
extreme daddy and sister issues a lot of
rage going on so me just gonna use her
imp is it empathy powers empathic powers
to kind of you know do nothing
how is she gonna do anything if she
needs to fight there's no way she's
gonna she's gonna do group therapy cells
to be a great hero in some of these
she's the therapist for nebula gone
rogue they refuse to work with other
people they've been doing their own
thing for so long also you have nebula
mantis who both come from one property
let's spread that out a little bit so
that way we can see more people and also
black widow needs to be in there she's
been there from the beginning from Iron
Man to she's the first woman that we've
had on this team she deserves to be just
because she's getting a solo movie
doesn't mean anything and like that's
ever gonna happen I mean sorry it who
knows if that's gonna ever happen I'm
still waiting though I mean it only took
18 movies to get to Black Panther so
another 24 and maybe we'll get to okay I
gotta stop but anyways
talk to us about your team Brienne and
how what each one would do how you'd use
Valkyrie gosh what each one would do
well it depends on like I didn't know
what's your story are you uh was I
supposed to come up with a story cuz
that wasn't really on my agenda you know
what come up with one right now
something to rival those those MCU sex
traffickers gosh I just feel like
Valkyrie would be the lead in this
especially because she was the one who
approached Feige about it and I feel
like she you use the correct term of
Lady liberators even though I would like
this to be like an a force film but I
why at the same time it's why is there
only three why can't we pick even more
than that because that was because
that's the question I mean otherwise we
can them all together okay okay pick
your 9th and another finger 19 favorite
random
characters I know I'm kidding we sorry
we need rules we need rules yes if I
could break the rules I put she-hulk in
there as well you're going on like this
is not gonna help your art my art but I
do feel like I do feel like it needs to
be spread out if we're gonna pick three
and four choosing two from the same one
that just kind of it almost undermines
all the other all the other females that
are in these movies gotcha
I'm gonna need to hear a little bit more
as far as a pitch as what your film
might feel like or how your team might
work in unison well I would I'm really
hoping that there's going to be some
sort of dance sequence because Black
Widow is a trained ballerina I'll have
you know okay I'll have you know but
maybe with horses because Valkyrie has a
horse that she rides on Oh much like the
dancing horses of Cavalia yes so are you
able to give me any more as far as what
your film might feel like and what the
plot might know how because the problem
is is that I wasn't prepared for that
okay so if that's what you wanted that's
what you should have asked for okay sure
sure
[Laughter]
what would the story be so I came up
with that on the fly too so I'm just
gonna throw that out there the reason I
picked these three women though these
three specific women is because yes
nebula and man cysts are part of the
same property but I really wouldn't buy
personality and who's gonna play off
each other the best versus who is from
what movie nebula washable loose cannon
she's gonna kill one of your other
characters before this movie she's like
maimed some people I don't know um who
would a bit who would the big bad be
that they'd be going up against bran the
big bad yes a madam someone's gonna play
a madam at this nope it's Cate Blanchett
traffic thing sure is there as there is
there any kind of puppet master pulling
the strings that we know from either the
MCU or from the comics I mean I guess it
would be um what Benicio did for his
character
the collector I mean he collects things
he collected two women we just saw that
so he's he's enslaving women so he's
they're gonna try and go liberate these
girls they're gonna try and save the day
interest or know their gender in the
race okay breanne no I don't got it I
don't have it
okay it's just not there sure sure
all right time wow what an epic
smackdown Valkyrie versus Valkyrie in
one universe yeah and there are so many
great women to choose from and
especially from Black Panther there were
so many strong women and you guys had
some great choices so this was a really
difficult decision for me because I
thought you breanne you had a great
takedown of Stacie's saying that mantis
would just be like a therapist and she
wouldn't be able to factor into the
action quite as much and I don't feel
like I think it's possible to defend
that but I don't feel like you quite
defended that but and then you pitched
something that was really dark darker
than anything I've ever imagined MCU but
but then you brought in Benicio del Toro
and I'm like yeah he he is this guy that
like takes people prisoner and he's
unscrupulous that character and I love
me some Benicio del Toro he was so great
in Star Wars and so that was really
interesting but Brienne yes
simply because you didn't put them in
any kind of vehicle or weren't able to
give me an idea of where it would go I
loved what you set up and I loved the
fact that you targeted Black Widow who's
so deserving of a film well this is
tearing me apart long
how's your sex life at the end of the
day hmm
simply because you painted the clearer
picture of how they would get on and how
the movie would pan out
I gotta go Stacy but you had some good
points lon
I too in terms of facts all the facts
that I heard were good mantis is an
empath black widow is a trained
ballerina and nebula has not killed
anyone in the MCU to my knowledge so I
was I was really disappointed that we
didn't get to hear more of a story
around Valkyrie black widow and Cherie I
thought in terms of the arguments that
were actually made I thought Brienne
pretty handily won the round
I didn't hear a lot back about the point
you brought up about mantis would
basically just be hanging around to be a
therapist I did I agree with Rand that
nebula and mantis are both sort of from
one property there's so many women from
so many of these different properties
that seems kind of a shame and I thought
that bran made a great case about black
widow deserving her own movie she's been
in the franchise since the very
beginning so I'm going with Brienne even
though we didn't get more of a fleshed
out pitch BAM all right let's go to the
internet to decide Danielle what do we
got all right so go into the polls fresh
fresh fresh polls
um leading with 51% to 41% the folks
have spoken and they like the team of
Valkyrie Black Widow and Sheree Brienne
takes the point
nicely done Brienne Chandler we got
ourselves a ball game Danielle any
cool stuff on the you're already being
memed I'm just you know David Dremel
posted Stacey you got the best game face
I'd be hella intimidated and then like
just took a screen cap of you with a
thing that says nice argument don't care
oh yeah we're on them sick memes and
maybe I have been getting all of your
core guys I'm sorry I haven't been able
to answer in time and Iron Mike Wilson
says a badass spy movie with black widow
Sheree and the wasp it would be like the
MCU version of Charlie's Angels except
good nice I like that oh so much love
for ya oh yeah okay Okoye brought it
aka Michonne just badass and Black
Panther okay nice so we are at two for
Stacey one for Brienne we're about to go
into the speed round but before we get
into all that goodness we got a little
bit of a sneak peak coming up this
weekend
dropping this weekend world premiere
serious questions about Harry Potter we
did this video before serious questions
about another franchise Star Wars
here comes serious questions about Harry
Potter let's check out this preview
Voldemort saw muggles is inferiors and
wanted to crush them under his boot so
shouldn't the good guys want the
opposite you know to blend their worlds
and live in peace no instead the good
guys think muggles are equal but keep
them separate separate but equal so make
a gif of me being like what the hell cuz
we don't have sound of the trailer the
describe EULA at one point pulls a
Ravager pilot out of his cockpit and
throws him to apparently his
death ons and are in guardians of the
galaxy one I apologize know what
important nebula hasn't killed anyone
that matters to us yes no matter that's
not that ravager not to me yes lon hates
the writers very anti ravager you know
right let's not get political on okay so
it is to one now we're going to the
speed round
the first combatant to get four points
is gonna walk out of here a winner the
other one is going to be hitchhiking
back to the middle of nowhere
alright and now Danielle she will she
might chime in on something cool that
she sees on the internet but she will be
judging from her own thoughts and
perceptions as well as lawn and myself
so the three of us will decide these
speed round answers Brienne Chandler are
you ready no I'm good Stacey Howard are
you ready
poppy nice okay on hold that thought and
let's jump in the speed round okay first
question
now that Joss Whedon is out who should
step into direct Batgirl say your answer
when you have it
say your answer when you have Jenkins
patty Jenkins okay Vernon Ava Duvernay
great patty Jenkins ava duvernay Stacy
smoke first you'll get 20 seconds then
you'll get 20 seconds and then you each
get a 10 second rebuttal
Stacy time begins whenever you speak
patty Jenkins just proved that she could
do an amazing origin story that hits it
big at the box office with critics and
with audiences with Wonder Woman why
don't we give her another chance to do
an incredible origin story with Batgirl
we haven't seen a lot of her yet this is
her first movie a lot riding on it she's
proven she can handle the pressure
can I hug you anymore that's all I have
time patty Jenkins did a great job with
Wonder Woman but she's done a great job
and now it's time to let another woman
do a great job and who else would I want
to see but Ava Duvernay I'm very much
looking forward to a wrinkle in time
just the visuals of the of the trailer
alone make me excited make me excited
for some what she could do with Batgirl
10 second rebuttal
I prefer patty Jenkins over Ava Duvernay
because I think she would handle a
property that's already had a lot of its
you know come books and out vs. Ava
Duvernay it's more original ava duvernay
is more into originals and that's why I
think it would be great to have an
original Batgirl movie someone with a
fresh take on it from maybe even just
Ground Zero I don't know if Ava Duvernay
is a comic book time Wow two great
directors compelling arguments Danielle
talk to us know both of these were great
arguments I what really clinched it for
me was when it was mentioned that Ava is
better handling things that were
original which wrinkle time is not
necessarily an original it is it is an
adaptation but I'd liked that Brienne
said that it would be really refreshing
to have a fresh take on a character
that's known so well from the comics so
I'm gonna go through him one Oh Brienne
Juan Harris you know I I thought
from based on what we heard we know
patty Jenkins can sort of knock this
kind of material out of the park and the
fact that she's sort of done it once and
did it great to me didn't really seem
like a great reason not to ever come
back and do it I'm going with Stacy
boom one one right there comes down to
me and yeah
Stacy you made a great argument at
aztlán said that patty Jenkins did knock
this very same kind of material a woman
who we haven't seen in her own
standalone movie out of the park also DC
but you I thought you had a nice
argument for Ava Duvernay and her
mastery of visuals and the original take
and you got me more excited to see Ava
Duvernay 's fresh take on this
especially with wrinkle and time so I
got to give it to Brienne and we are all
locked up at 2-2
the owl memes are coming fast and hard
[Laughter]
great second question of the speed round
Fox Searchlight is developing a film
based on flamin hot cheetos what snack
food would inspire the best movie
classic sometimes I love snacks just
getting all the time what snack food
would inspire the best movie v zebra
cake for Pirate's Booty okay Stacy you
smoke first 20 seconds begin whenever
you begin speaking doesn't necessarily
have to be a comedy zebra cakes gonna be
zebras or being mated in cakes and the
heroes of the zebra community have to
stop them let's do a dark gritty real
version of you know Soylent Green but
it's zebras that's literally all I have
just could ride it out a frightening
movie Brianne okay so Pirate's Booty I
think we're gonna do this as a kid's
film so a kid's pirate movie you know
Jake and the Never Land pirates let's
bring that make it even bigger make it
even better have them have to look for
the pirates booty or as the pirates
booty the fuel for them I'm gonna let
you decide if you want it to be the fuel
or what they are looking for but pirates
booty with jake and the neverland
pirates
time ten-second rebuttal I don't have
kids I don't want to see a kids movie I
want to see a pretty realistic version
of what would happen Green okay that
would be insanely crazy
okay would that be like Animal Farm
because I feel like that's animals I'm
sure like green together but I don't
want to see your movie only because
that's very dark and sad and I want to
do time all right Wow
yeah you got me thinking about like
zebras going in like a meat grinder
awful it was frightening our zebra cakes
like what our zebra cakes it's a white
cake and it's got vanilla cream oh it's
like hostess yeah okay so yeah made out
of meat like okay so movie it is okay
you know it's very sad frightening I
gotta go with Brienne on this one
Danielle I Wow
okay I I I love that you think that the
executives of zebra cakes are gonna be
like you know what's gonna sell zebra
cakes had some real zebra what's gonna
sell their product I I really enjoyed
both arguments as dark as they were but
I do have to say the idea of looking for
a pirates booty is fuel it was given me
some gummy bears vibes and it sounded
really fun and refreshing and not
something terrifying that would make me
never want to eat cake again I do think
if they ever made the zebra cakes movie
how you should have to go watch it with
your bomb Oh
yeah I don't want to see that that
murder fest that zebra murder fest okay
it is three two Brienne she storms into
the lead all right by the way
Stacy needs this question to stay in the
game bran takes it she takes the match
Disney wants to bring back the Muppets
for a new streaming series what's the
best muppet movie Muppets Take Manhattan
we heard Muppets Take Manhattan some up
a movie The Muppet movie all right
Muppets Take Manhattan Muppet movie
Stacey you spoke first begin when
justification sorry when you say the
Muppet movie you mean like the one from
the 80s seven not with Jason Segel no
okay the original the og okay so we got
the og we got Muppets Take Manhattan you
spoke first 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak now Muppets Take Manhattan is
home alone - lost in New York you want
to see the Muppets go on an adventure
okay we already had an entire show where
you see who they are and how they work
together we want to see them out into
the world interacting with other people
to see that juxtaposition that weird you
know transition between Muppet and
mankind it just throws you for a loop
and it really just explore the
imagination I'm the Muppet movie is
better than Muppets Take Manhattan
because this is a journey film we are
going from one place to another place we
are trying to make a movie while we are
doing it and we're meeting a lot of
different colorful characters along the
way and also animal becomes really large
at the end and I don't really understand
why that happens but I find it
fascinating every time that it does the
end rebuttal
I just think that Manhattan is one of
the best places to hold a film because
it has so much to offer and so much
interaction with every kind of person
that there is so that's why I love that
movie I want to see the Muppets interact
with every kind of New Yorker The
Muppets Take Manhattan I don't want to
see it because Kermit loses his memory
and we don't want to see him lose his
memory the entire time we want to see
him fun and interactive with all the
other Muppets and kind of leading the
force and we don't see that in Memphis
take Manhattan time all right let's go
to lon
well I mean these are both great movies
I think we heard some pretty good
arguments for both but it just felt like
Brienne had a lot better handle on the
content of the movies and was able to
use a lot more examples of great moments
from her movie so I got to go Brienne
that's 104 Brienne Daniel Radford I did
a lot of them were the same kind of
arguments like it was they were very
similar I did like Stacie's argument New
York really is the 60th character and
weapons take Manhattan but I do also see
like the allure of having Kermit but on
this one I had to go Stacey okay so it's
tied up 1-1 yeah you both had some
strong arguments for the movies that you
chose but I thought Breanna was the only
one who had the takedown of the other
part the strongest takedown of the other
person's movie talking about you know
Kermit's memory and how we don't quite
want that and at the end of the day I
got to go Brianne Brianne places you
just one more fight
[Applause]
good times come to drink from the
chalice of victory do I get to drink
from the chalice of victory yes when you
get home and pour something into your
own chalice okay chalice is nothing very
exciting especially because I want to
point on a round that I was like that's
my weakest one looking at my nose
well welcome to movie I know sometimes
the unexpected happened go ahead and
plug some stuff one more time plug some
stuff one more time you can find me and
Stacy on my youtube channel which is
youtube.com slash miss movies where we
do two live weekly shows a week Stacy
and I do 6° a feature film on Wednesdays
at 10:30 a.m. PST I do film therapy on
Thursdays at 10:30 a.m. PST and that's
where you can find us you can find me on
Twitter as well this movie nicely done
Stacy Howard you brought it this was a
great match we went deep into the speed
round and yeah if it wasn't for her
comeback you would have walked out of
here Champa instead you're a roller
skating home please go ahead and plug
some stuff tell us where we can find you
uh you can find me on Twitter Instagram
and snapchat at Stacy Oh Howard no II
know I just why as Bryan pitched
beautifully we do have a show together
Wednesday morning six degrees two
feature film talking movies all the time
I feel like I need to admit that I've
never seen him up at movies so it was
really hard for me to argue that but
know today was amazing I was happy to go
against my friend I think we both had a
really good time and I was glad to be
back in these Studios I haven't been
here in a while it was awesome having
you you had some great debates you both
loved Valkyrie and by the way if if
you've been on movie fights and you
haven't had to pull some crap out of
your ass
then you haven't movie fought okay um
Daniel Radford hello um you guys can
find me here all the time especially on
Thursdays I have a podcast called at
tights fights or where you can find us
on Twitter its tights and fights it's
about wrestling also I want to give a
shout out to at me theists underscore LA
and I did my best
Angie and Marco to fans just got engaged
[Music]
[Applause]
they're very very cute and probably
happy and marriage is great
Congrats Angie and Marco Juan Harris
thanks for holding it down on the facts
and the whatnots my always a pleasure to
be here and discuss my hatred for all
Ravagers
very anti Ravager they're very Pro
Valkyrie and I'm very Pro you watching
thank you so much for checking out some
movie fight today I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter at Hal Rudnick Instagram
at Hal Rudnick and yeah
thanks Billy bears thanks JT e aka te
bye everybody bye bye
you